but next up on the lobby we're gonna be
talking about the Star Wars season pass
announcement the beta is wrapping up you
have a couple more hours to get into
that but for you ostensibly like there's
no more time to play what we did learn a
lot more about the season pass I'm
joined on the couch by Mike McCarty Rob
handler II and Aaron what do you guys
think so having played a lot of time
with the beta I that was extended Oh
much longer than we thought it was gonna
be what are your overall impressions so
9 they said City 9 million people played
the beta and to me that says that this
was a demo given yeah yeah the words
that we use around those a lot of times
I think that they do say beta when this
is in fact a demo the game is so close
to launch it's gonna be coming out soon
this might be a little bit of testing
the servers and stressing them and
making sure that they work but for the
game itself this is the fully finished
product this is the game as its that's
what I went to it assuming like this
late in the in the cycle like I'm sure
the discs are already going off to print
and no people who have their pre-orders
and are making their decisions right
about now whether to keep them or ditch
them I was left with kind of a little
bit of concern from the beta we saw
three maps and Rob's also seen Endor and
every single time we've seen this game
there's always been just something to
every single map or you're like I'm not
so sure about this like Walker assault
on Hoth was so imbalanced towards the
Imperials and and to be fair to beta and
balance can be tweaked and fixed but in
this case I don't know how it got
through anyway to that point like I
wonder what the creative process was
that allowed the Imperials to have their
80s tea Walker's literally walk into the
rebel spawn the spawn kill everybody or
like a turret that fired directly into
the rebel base and killed everybody or
an 8080 walker that fired into the rebel
base and killed everybody like and you
can't choose your spawn it's something
as simple as not even letting players
choose where they're gonna start to get
the objective grading you could you
could spawn on a partner but you know
you think of battlefield like spawning
or Lobby menu
there's at least a freakin map like you
know what I mean like I would actually
that's what I'm just realizing now is do
you know there isn't a map to see what's
what's going on in the battlefield right
now where my guys what tactical location
can I come in and help out it's just so
up in the air like you know we put
footage up with like an ATSC rampage I
had as an imperial and I just planked
around on the side Lane and just started
owning people
I got like 15 kills because they're
spawning in groups like you know six
guys at once and I'm just annihilating
them and there's nothing they can do
they have no control over their spawning
so that was that was just like the
Walker saw it on Hoth drop zone on
Sullust was just like a model of
simplicity and it was so simple and the
pacing was so consistent that I tend to
find those things get boring just
because the map didn't have any terrain
variety to it it was all lava fields
with little pools that burned your
ankles and one landing pad with a ship
you couldn't interact with so like maybe
that that might be DICE's so like in
battlefield what they would do is they
would take a large map in section off a
small area for team deathmatch style
modes so it's possible that map to be
fair is much larger and has interesting
sections and that was just a boring
section to pick for the map and then
survival on Tatooine they only allowed
normal mode and in normal mode the enemy
AI like would fall asleep fighting you
like I had an ATS D just kind of drift
off in the middle of a gun battle and
like kind of lost focus on board yeah
like like a so again like all all of the
things that were curated for this demo I
just I just found problems with but its
overall I mean this is something that is
at the end of the day it's a marketing
tool it's trying to get you to try out
the game and enough people play that you
said over 9 million people and they
extended it long enough that it seems
like on that sense of a6 success Mike
what do you think after having played it
is this something that you feel like I I
want to pre-order it or are you still
kind of waiting for it to see what the
review is gonna shake out to be I don't
know that a pre-order I didn't play as
extensively as these two or a few people
in the office but
I had fun with it I wasn't I don't know
that I went into it looking for like a
balance as much as I would with a lot of
shooters but it was just great to be
back in the Star Wars universe but will
that get me excited to pay for the
season pass and pre-order the game I
don't think so I think I would hesitate
yeah so you're not gonna buy the season
pass from this I'm not I'm probably
gonna handle it just like I did with
battlefield 4 I bought I bought
battlefield 4 and then bought one
expansion and then yeah I got I drifted
away
I've been again I'm not like a it used
to be in the Saint battlefield guy but
so that's my own reason there but buying
$120 worth for this game and having this
beta experience you there's no way
there's no way you do it but you
mentioned dying this is like the
battlefield experience and then it's
gonna follow that same that same set up
that same algorithm where you have four
packs we don't know exactly what's gonna
be offered in them but there's gonna be
some assortment probably of new maps and
maybe some some new modes having seen
that from the battlefield model why is
that not something that you want to
carry over into Star Wars traditionally
and you can speak over yeah I mean
traditionally battlefield 3 & 4 had at
least one DLC that I didn't like
they were mostly had to do with taking a
large battlefield and making it to close
quarters they did that twice in a row on
their first DLC and so already like I
had already paid for one of four DLCs
that I didn't like ahead of time so I've
gotten to a point now where I'm wait and
just see how the DLC is before I'll buy
it and if there's even one DLC that you
don't like you've like saved yourself
$15 or whatever out of you know the
pricing model right now again like this
game though is very simple I think it's
very casual and I think of those 9
million people like you pretty much know
right away whether you like it or not
because the design decisions are so
specific not being able to choose your
spawn not having extensive load outs you
know like having the game choose when
and where you go a lot of times you'll
know whether you like that or not right
away and I think that there won't be a
hard decision for casual players to make
well I just wanted to say we're seeing a
lot of aerial combat I did a video air
combat is so confusing it needed to be
one-to-one like so for instance when you
see a barrel roll this it's just such a
weird design choice you do a barrel roll
I'm sorry I barrel a flip you're gonna
be upside down the game doesn't know
like it then has to be like okay well
now I'm upside down how the hell do I
get back right side up your controls are
the same for left and right in that yaw
and roll are the same one direction so
you're upside down the controls are just
so weird and bizarre here you are
automatically being swung into a hill
when you're doing the snowspeeder I
don't know so so thank you
was that 8080 pretty much invulnerable
to those two the tow cable when it was
next to that hill it becomes vulnerable
in the very very last portion of the
fight in which you can tow cable it and
oftentimes the timer would run out while
you're in the QTE so even though you
would have cinched the Walker you would
lose because the timer ran out like
again it's these you have a demo you
have a curated demo and what you've
shown is mostly concerning me and you
know when you ask the question about
pre-orders that means no I'm not gonna
pre-order it now I'm open to the
possibility that they're good there's
gonna be good modes and maps in this
game there's a couple things that I'm
looking forward to like supremacy is
gonna be their conquest mode and it's
this sort of tug of war conquest mode so
that's actually could be really cool
cargo sounds a lot like capture the flag
or obliteration from battlefield
hardline obliteration was a great mode
in battlefield 4 and Droid run might
solve the problems of drop zone by it
looks like it like the droids move
around right so instead of just guarding
static things that the droids are
running around so like already there's
like that's probably about half of the
modes that I'm interested in the other
half the modes when I flip through the
menus I am definitely not interested in
like they're team deathmatch not
interested in air supremacy their
Fighter Squadron mode like not
interested in so you know like there's
half the content that I'm like
tentatively looking forward to seeing
but in Rob as one of the biggest Star
Wars fans in the office
I think that there has to be some diaz
there has me some maps or something that
you're like
or even even though I'm on the fence now
like as soon as they announcement no I
have to order that as soon as I know
that's in the game exactly and that's
that's where I'm on the fence I'm so
looking forward to this movie and I
watched the trailer about like five
times every day but the movie you know
as you can imagine the seasons are gonna
correspond to the movie you're gonna see
like you know in the trailer the x-wings
booking in on the water probably gonna
be in our security or the security
already map you're gonna have these
correlations you're like oh man that'll
be really cool one of what a memorable
moment from the movie that I'd love to
play that's where I'll probably get I'll
get sucked in but um I gotta play the
game the actual game first I'm not gonna
make that call under 20 bucks is way too
much is there anything that would pull
you in like yeah I mean like Aaron had
said I think I'm just more of the person
who would want to see how each
individual pack plays out I would not
mind spending $15 for you know another
planet to play on or however they choose
to separate in whatnot but and I'm
nowhere near as close as Rob or like a
bunch people the office I'm a huge Star
Wars fan but I I just can't I don't know
what they would need to do for me to
just say yes I will preorder it I will
pay $120 so I can prolong this
experience for that long because right
now it seems bare bone from my
impression I've played a few hours I
haven't played a ton and I don't see
that being worth that money but I'm
hoping they can convince me well last
question for each of you guys we've had
some leaks come out of the game that we
know there's gonna be some additional
characters han and and Leia the Emperor
as hero powers they're gonna be able to
get and possibly some new skins for it
for those hero powers as well
what kind of additions like that would
you like to see in the game like whether
it's even possible or not or whether
it's realistic what what's your kind of
dream wish if you throw Boba Fett in
there oh it's coming I'm yeah yes yeah
as a hero pumping water less as you can
control him in the slave 1 and as well
as the real deal yeah words or widget
weapon assault Wicca yeah whomp assault
like beans
don't take yourself as seriously just do
tapas give you wampas how about that
what's up
Clark our name the like you've seen the
trailer like that like the silver
stormtrooper captain like he'll asthma
he looked like a dark trooper the first
time I saw he'd be awesome hi you might
be a lady trooper oh she is yeah cool
it's the girl from what's your name from
Brienne of Tarth yes your throne thank
you yeah yes you totally kicks ass yeah
those are a lot of cool things we might
see potentially I think they take our
ideas I think they listen to us and
those are the things they're gonna put
into the game star wars battlefront
launches on diverse November 17th
one month after that you will to see the
force awakens in theaters on December
18th and for even more GameSpot or even
more Star Wars stuff stay tuned to game
spot
[Music]